we're now only around five months away
from Apple's iPhone 14 lineup reveal and
we keep getting better and better leaks
that are making me so excited for the
new iPhone 14 lineup especially the pro
model so in this video I'm gonna go
through those leaks and talk about why
they are such a big deal but then I'm
also going to talk about the future
iPhone 15 lineup that we should be
getting next year and how that is going
to compare so with that said let's go
ahead and break down everything we
should be expecting for the iPhone 14
before getting into the 15. now first of
all I have my Twitter page open right
here and I did work with renders by
Shailesh to create some brand new iPhone
14 renders look at that design you have
a camera bump that is larger than the
one on the iPhone 13 Pro I have my Max
model right here I cannot believe it's
going to be larger than this and there's
actually a very very good reason for it
which I'm going to get into in just a
second and of course we have the Dual
hole punch camera and this is actually a
new kind of Golden Bronze copper-ish
color and I think it looks beautiful so
here are some more renders I'm going to
quickly list through them before I move
on to the leaks and how we got to these
renders now for months everyone was
thinking we'd be getting a flat back
design with glass on both sides but last
month Max Weinbach came out and revealed
some new renders on March 22nd he showed
a camera bump just like we have right
now of course with that new dual cutout
and a lot of people were initially
doubting it until more and more leaks
came out especially shrimp Apple Pro who
was the first leaker to leak the Dual
cutout design he came out earlier this
month and revealed some brand new cads
and these are by far the most deta
tailed cats that I've seen and they have
some really awesome details that have
not been shown before but the big point
I want to show you is a super thin
earpiece speaker and he actually went
and gave us all of these different
measurements and descriptions showing
like how far away the hole punches are
going to be and the height of the
earpiece which is basically three times
thinner than the current one on the 13
pro model so that was a lot of
confirmation right there and
unfortunately he told us that we are not
getting USBC with the iPhone 14 it's
still gonna stick with lightning which
is extremely disappointing and I'll
explain why in just a minute but first
of all there were some other leakers
like Majin Buu who showed us some
comparisons of what that new dual cutout
would look like and as you can see this
really makes the Iphone 14 pro look
immersive Ian Zelda also showed off
those thin bezels and man I know a lot
of people are saying that it does
doesn't look good but I can't wait I
think a lot of people are going to be
impressed when they actually see the
phone in real life but now let's get
into the brand new leak that is getting
me super excited it literally just came
out this morning Ming Chico is saying
that the iPhone 14 models are likely to
feature an upgraded front camera with
auto focus the current selfie camera on
the iPhones is fixed Focus so the lens
does not move so that means it's just
generally in focus it hopes you're not
too close otherwise it's going to be
blurry but it generally works at an
aperture of f 2.2 however the new one is
going to have auto focus support and a
lower F stop so F 1.9 and that is going
to allow more light to come into the
sensor and that is going to be a big
deal for improving the nighttime
photography nighttime selfies and it's
also going to help improve those
portrait selfies because it's naturally
going to have more blur so it's going to
make it easier for the software to kind
of do the blur edging around your face
and on top of that mexical was saying
right here that the extra autofocus is
going to enhance the focus effect for
Facetime video calling and live
streaming so when you have that
background blur effect turned on during
face time it's going to make it easier
and more accurate now I know the entire
iPad lineup has transitioned to using
the 12 megapixel Ultra wide camera with
Center Stage support where it basically
follows you around wherever you go now
some people were thinking that Apple
would put that ultrawide camera onto the
iPhones but based on the numbers and the
aperture that I'm seeing here I do not
think that is the case first of all if
you look at the iPad Pro with the ultra
wide camera it has an F 2.4 aperture and
that's because when you go Ultra wide it
it's harder to have a faster f-stop or
taking in more light it's harder to make
that happen without making the lens
massive so because of this the fact that
apple is going reverse and letting in
more light with an F 1.9 aperture kind
of shows that it's going to be another
12 megapixel camera that's just going to
be better with better lenses I mean
hopefully it might be like a 16
megapixel that would really be awesome
or maybe even more but I don't think it
is going to be ultra wide now moving on
we finally got our first iPhone 14 molds
as you can see here is our lineup we now
finally have two iPhone 14 Max models we
have the regular one as you can see
right here it has just the Dual lenses
then you have the pro Max one thing I
can tell is that the actual camera
lenses themselves are wider they're just
bulkier compared to the ones on the
regular models look at how massive this
camera bump is compared to the size of
this 6.1 inch iPhone it is huge and if
you are wondering why it is that big
let's get right into it over a full year
ago Ming Shaco came out and said that
the 2022 iPhones will feature a main 48
megapixel camera that can shoot 8K video
so that is why the camera bumps are
going to be just so massive this year
because we're getting the biggest camera
update and change that we have ever seen
on the iPhone ever now moving on we
actually got a weibo leak talking about
the main Sony sensor that's going to be
going into the iPhone 14 Pro Models
first of all they gave us info on the
sensor size which is absolutely massive
one by 1.3 millimeter so it's going to
be huge and it confirms that they are
going to be able to record 8K video at
60 FPS at least the sensor is capable of
doing this now with that said those were
the leaks for the iPhone 14 lineup and I
personally think that they are going to
be huge however
the leaks that we thought we were gonna
get this year in terms of the brand new
redesign with the glass on both sides as
you can see in this render that I had
renders by Shailesh create for me you
have glass on both sides and you have
the protruding camera bumps right there
along with a circular volume buttons
which were actually leaked from Front
Page Tech and according to this video he
made he basically admitted that the real
iPhone 14 is not gonna have a flat glass
back he basically said that sometimes he
gets his leaks early so he believes that
the leaks that he got in terms of the
glass on both sides with the flush back
design and the single camera cutouts he
thinks those are actually destined for
next year's iPhone 15 instead now with
that said I did make a video on how the
iPhone 14 pro could have USBC and that
was based around the fact that it was
going to be getting this full redesign
with the titanium chassis it looks like
we are not going to be potentially
getting USBC until next year or apple
might go all out remove the ports
completely and go fully Wireless that
might be one reason why you might skip
out on the iPhone 14 lineup this year
and just wait another year with your
current phone and just look at this this
is a darker model you can see the glass
on both sides you see these new speaker
grilles which are based on John
Prosser's leaks and you have USB type c
we are rumored to be getting a new
Periscope telephoto zoom lens on the
iPhone 15 Pro Models next year so if
you're someone who really really cares
about taking photos or video zoomed in
that 5x lens is probably going to be
really killer in terms of quality we
actually do have some new patents from
patently Apple showing how LG initech is
likely to be a key supplier for the
Periscope lens and we actually have some
of these Apple patents right here and we
also have another one where it says that
Apple may use ball guide actuators and
more for the future iPhone with a
periscope zoom lens system but let's go
ahead and answer the original question
do I think that you should wait for the
iPhone 15 models next year or just wait
a few months more for the 14. well first
of all if you care a lot about camera
quality I think the new 48 megapixel
camera is going to be a massive deal the
biggest camera update but if that's not
really that big of a deal to you and you
don't really care about this new Duo cut
out design then I'd say you might as
well wait for the next iPhone because
the redesign is going to be the big deal
and as soon as those iPhone 15 Pro
Models start coming out the old ones are
going to feel a little bit more dated so
with that said I think the 14 is going
to be a killer upgrade and if you're
thinking about buying the 13 right now I
would definitely suggest just holding
off a little bit a few more months and
just going with the 14 pro model because
we know it's going to be a killer
upgrade so hopefully you enjoy this
video and if you did go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one definitely check
out one of those two right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]